how about these 10 million renters right
now
that the bailout for renting is coming
up in 30 days yeah 10 million
okay what are they going to be doing
we've been paying their rent for 10
do you know what a catastrophic issue
that is if we can no longer bail these
guys out
for how many months have they not been
paid right 15. can you tell us about
this 10 million because you wrote about
it
yes so that's coming um so the
moratorium on
you know not being able to evict people
is going to end
it's ending and when is it july first
yeah so you know
that these landlords will do it
immediately they're pissed off i mean
they haven't been getting paid
you know it's caused a lot of hardship
for people that own these businesses as
well so
it's a real deal and it's gonna
adversely affect the african-american
community i mean it's right there in the
story the whole thing
so um yeah because the left they can
only think day-to-day they only think
about you know making people like them
for one more day and to keep them
acceptable and keep them in office
they're not they don't care about any
long-term
solutions or using any any real you know
strategy to fix this stuff but that's
coming
and if i know landlords and i know
renters and it's going to be affecting
them because
i mean this is important to read there's
a lifetime thrown to 10 million plus
struggling renters in the u.s has only
30 days
to run and many of the americans face
eviction the center for disease control
and prevention helped to establish an
eviction
moratorium that began last september and
provide assistance in the wake up
pandemic
today with reports indicating millions
are behind on their payments
there's real danger coming as the june
30th deadline approaches
by the way this is real you you really
want to see protesting
raise gas prices you really want to see
protesting give people free rent for
months and all of a sudden tell them
it's going to go away
watch the real kind of protesting you're
going to see and then what are you going
to do like you said
next year what's coming another stimulus
another stimulus and then all of a
sudden we're sitting there saying
we have taught the american people in
the last four years we can send the
money
we can send the money and then gas
prices go to 10 bucks then they're gonna
say
how can you raise gas prices ten bucks
you asked for it
you asked for it yeah this is what took
place and this is gonna i mean this is
if you really think about the impact of
this because covet and everything just
it gave you this sense
this false sense of security like you're
gonna get these stimulus checks things
are going to be taken care of but this
is real there's going to be people on
the streets here
in 30 days which is the last thing this
country needs is more homeless
adam thoughts no that's it's going to be
a major issue
i i and my prediction is that they're
going to extend the moratorium past
june 30th god how much longer can they i
agree i
agree i think uh i think at the end of
the day
september is going to be the de facto
date where all this is going to come to
an end because kids got to go back to
school
life has to go back to normal uh you
might want to give people a heads up
not that there isn't a heads up already
30 days and i'm sure if you're getting
your rent paid for you're
very closely tracking the story but at
the end of the day i wholeheartedly
agree with you we can't just keep
printing money like this
it's absurd and giving people ice cream
because they ate their food
is a very good analogy right here and i
agree with you so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye